show me
an Ohio man wanted for murder leads
police on a high-speed chase that ends
in a crash after he drove through city
streets at more than 100 miles per hour
break out Raquel wreck out on June 1st
investigators say 57-year-old William
Jerry Hefner shot and killed 48-year-old
Matthew Smith in Dayton Ohio they
confirmed with witnesses that Hefner
fled the scene driving off in a red
pickup truck days later on June 7th
Dayton Police spotted Hefner's truck
A340 dispatch and on West 2nd continuing
on North on Anna Jan F 7481 red Ford
F-150
[Music]
Speedway near me
dash camera video shows an officer turn
on his sirens and follow Hefner who
refuses to slow down or pull over
come on
[Music]
the officer leading the chase can be
heard calling for backup before Hefner
is seen driving through someone's lawn
in an effort to escape
Tyson
[Music]
he's continuing uh Northbound on Tyson
about six minutes into the chase a
second cop car can be seen approaching
right on Hefner's tail
[Music]
s
foreign
the Second Officer follows Hefner noting
he's speeding nearly 100 miles per hour
traffic's moderate speeds are
approaching 100. dash camera video then
captures a sudden turn by Hefner who
crashes his truck
out rock out wreck out video from the
other officers dash camera video shows
the aftermath of the crash
I don't know
[Music]
following the crash multiple officers
rush out of their squad cars headed for
Hefner nearly immediately they pull him
from the crashed truck
show me this do it now show me your
hands show me
hang on go get him on the other side get
him on the other side
pull him out
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
video then shows officers handcuffed
Hefner who is Bloody from the crash all
right all right Slow Down slow down slow
down slow down oh
get a good search on him
oh
good work people
your gloves on keep your gloves on
our time now okay
we've got a minute yeah
oh
all right
for now just for now until we get
everything done did you already do the
other side yeah
sorry
all right let's get him up you can throw
them in my bag after he's cuffed Hefner
is placed in the back of a squad car
bend your knees up bend your knees up
sit
get your legs underneath you oh
watch his elbow oh yeah oh yeah
all right
for his car we're going to
we can go to mine he's all right oh
oh gosh
she's not in good
yeah
I have a seat turn right yep
oh all right just have a seat there oh
my head Hefner was later indicted by a
grand jury on multiple counts including
two counts of murder and three counts of
felonious assault he's set to appear in
court on Tuesday reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie